[Music]
we are now
finally moving
after six months of australia's
efforts
the iea is moving in
to the zaporizia nuclear power plant as
you know we have a very very important
task
there
to perform
to assess the real situation
there
to help
stabilize the situation and as much as
we can well the mission will take a few
days
and if we
are able to establish a permanent
presence
or a continued presence
better said
then it's going to be prolonged but this
first segment
is going to take a few days
you know without clarity my mission is a
technical
it's a mission that seeks to prevent a
nuclear accident
and to preserve
this
important the largest the biggest
nuclear power plant in europe with the
whole of europe not only in ukraine so
this is what we are concentrating choice
this is uh should be a step to do they
occupied the militarize the station
because that is really very important
also very important
always from our uh our views is that
the mission could
could speak to to the person to the
staff
could get the the real information not
to rush on information to get the real
information what is the site first of
all uh but what is really very important
that we need to check
the real the situation on the npp
because uh
we have uh now
uh the soldiers there we have the
the heavy heavy vehicles there so we
need to to check what is really from the
point of view of nuclear safety and
security that's that's the
first of all
[Music]
robot
[Music]
you